let's read this first story and i'll
just highlight a couple little snippets
and then we'll just dive into this
conversation
cnn of all outlets right now surprising
they report southwest border crisis
leaves biden vulnerable on all sides
they say the white house may be loath to
call the situation on the southwestern
border
which hundreds of migrant children are
crossing alone a crisis
but it's fast becoming a political
emergency for the president
we have fox news reporting that
encounters have topped 100
000 in just february as the migrant
crisis
is spiraling so here it comes and uh you
know so so
alan you're in texas yeah you're the
chairman of the republican party i mean
this is an issue that's
very seriously affecting you it's
incredibly affecting us and one of the
things you have to understand is that
texas is the number one state in the
united states of america
for human and sex trafficking dallas and
houston are the top two cities
so that's an important part when you
start to have all of these
unaccompanied minors that are being
brought in what happens to them when
they're just released
into the society as a matter of fact
they're looking at bringing 3 000
of these illegal immigrants into dallas
to put them at the k bayley hutchinson
convention center then where do they go
from there these are minors these are
miners
and so when you understand that
atmosphere when you understand the
illegality of drugs to the cross and the
drug cartels
and how they're getting richer it comes
back to a very simple premise
why do you break something that is
working if it ain't broke don't fix it
and so you had an immigration situation
that the uh the bite administration took
over it was fine
no one's talking about it everything is
okay but
because you are so owing to the
progressive socialists
left and they have this open borders
agenda
then you make the faux pas of going in
and creating
a catastrophic situation by executive
order
and now you don't have a means by which
you're going to take care of it and the
important thing that
the the bite administration needs to
understand right now there's no orange
man bad
yeah there's no donald trump boogeyman
out there for people to to to look at
and
have that distraction now although
they're doing is saying
we got an issue we got a crisis and no
gen psyche you can't circle back to it
you can't say that this is just a
challenge this is affecting people
black white hispanic republican democrat
independent libertarian whatever you
want to call it because
you are destabilizing one of the largest
states in the united states of america
well something interesting you just
mentioned it was working right
yeah the system was working well pelosi
says the biden administration inherited
quote a broken system at the border this
is from the hill on march 14th
so they're already deflecting and i
think you know i've covered the the
migrant crisis throughout the past
several years extensively
the the number of encounters and migrant
children had dropped dramatically
incredibly so under under donald trump
yeah i mean what we're talking about in
the entire last year
is what we've already seen in the last
six weeks
and so this is a crisis situation and
and
you know again they can try this
deflection but the hypocrisy
becomes absolutely laughable if it
weren't so serious it's kind of like you
know the cuomo
kavanaugh you know hypocrisy but they
they can't fall back
and say well this is trump's fault i'm
sorry orange man is gone
literally pelosi is trying to do that
they're trying to resurrect the
boogeyman but it's just not going to
work you know you know
banning him from twitter sure did
backfire on the left because trump would
be tweeting right now he's silent
yep nothing is nothing and you know what
i would say president trump if you're
watching me remember me i used to be
your congressman because mar-a-lago was
in my district stay silent
allow them as napoleon would say never
interfere with your enemy when they are
destroying themselves
what um what was this executive order
that biden signed that's screwing with
the border right now
well he basically has said one of the
things was that there will be no
deportations
and our attorney general sued him on
that but he is also
you know you guys won right yeah we want
that we we have a stay on that so we can
continue to deport
but one of the things that he did was he
said that this whole thing about
you must stay on the southern side of
the border in order to be processed for
your asylum
that's over now and so now they
understand that
they can do the asylum processing in the
united states of america and that's why
they're flooding in
and we have gone back to the catch and
release system where
you know everything about this covet
but yet you had 108 illegal immigrants
that tested positive for covet in
brownsville texas
and they were taken to a bus station and
they were released
so is the buying administration serious
about covet
i would think that you would not allow
108 illegal immigrants
just flow right into the state there's a
lot of hypocrisy
tons and it's it's kind of crazy how
often we can all bring it up
and it doesn't seem to change but what i
do notice is that one of the areas of
hypocrisy is the the woke critical race
theory type people the progressives
they use the phrase latin x something
that most latinos don't
recognize or even use and what's
fascinating is
the shift in the southern counties in
texas yes
mainly latino went for trump yes
dramatically
that was a huge that was a huge story of
the november 2020 election
in texas uh and and my theory was that
kind of like the mentality of
paratroopers
paratroopers jump in behind enemy lines
and so
why didn't we just go and take our
message into the areas where they
thought they were strong into
the rio grande valley and talk about our
principles and values talk about
the open borders talk about illegal
immigration talk about
strong families strong small business
entrepreneurship better education
opportunities
not defunding the police talk about the
threats from the drug cartels
and guess what they're like yeah and
when you look at the policies of
president trump where you had
record unemployment in the hispanic
community when you look at the oil and
gas industry that was thriving which
meant good paying jobs black white
hispanic it doesn't matter
then they said yeah we we like this
direction
now all of a sudden this joe biden comes
in
and their communities are being
threatened the drug cartels are
being empowered the illegal immigrants
are coming back in which means
a taxing on them and their tax base to
provide
you know additional services it means a
lack of safety and security
so they are alienating further
this area that they once thought they
completely controlled
this is a big big story of the of
the november election as you mentioned
the you know trump winning over more
votes for minority communities across
the board
most in 60 years yeah that's something
to stress
i mean when they talk about donald trump
as a racist then explain to me
how he had the most minority electoral
support
of any republican in 60 years at running
for president and
who did he lose he lost white voters
yeah
and so i wonder who is really buying
into this this message
about immigration you know trump is
racist for wanting to
uh you know deport illegal immigrants
and things like that certainly isn't the
minority communities that are literally
on the borders who are experiencing what
happens with unfettered
or the black communities they're going
to see their wages being depressed their
job opportunity is going to be gone as
well
and they saw that they were thriving in
the trump administration but look at it
and think about it this way the suburban
white woman
that was told again orange man bad he's
a nasty person he doesn't like women his
tree
tweets are horrible now all of a sudden
the suburban soccer mom
has to ask herself why is this six foot
two
gender dysphoric biological male gonna
be on the soccer field with my daughter
that's not what they voted for well they
should have paid attention to what they
were voting for
but but again now that's why it comes
back to that poll that you just talked
about
how a lot of people don't see joe biden
as being
capable of being the president and all
of these things that he is implementing
by way of the leftist agenda
and it's going to be the same thing for
young people i mean
i think that with president trump you
had a a cultural president connected
with young people he's a little rough or
whatever but
that's something that you get with a new
yorker but now you have someone that
you know if if you think that free
equals freedom you're horribly wrong
yeah one of the one of the main issues
that seems to have been lost on the left
is the economics of
mass migration and illegal immigration
that even bernie sanders was criticizing
back in 2015.
here's this guy he's the champion of the
left and the progressives and in 2015 he
said
open borders is a koch brothers proposal
he was basically saying these big
billionaire industrialists
want cheap people with no rights with no
with you know that
they can get in there for below minimum
wage and they need these policies in
order to do it
and there were big scandals i remember i
watched a documentary where some of
these companies would bring in illegal
immigrant labor
promise them a bunch of money and at the
end of the month just call immigration
and have them all deported
and they were exploiting these loopholes
they wanted that that porous border for
this
for this purpose but that means these
factories were actually taking away
good paying jobs for low-skilled labor
in these areas for working-class
americans you're absolutely right and
that's why you see the u.s chamber of
commerce that it's all about
you know the open borders and the
illegal immigration that's why you see a
lot of these big businesses and
corporations don't want e-verify
because what is he verified he verifies
the system by which people are
registered and you can track individuals
they don't want that
and so you have you have some
partisanship
on either side with this this issue one
people want to bring a new victim class
they want a new voter base the other
side wants to have a cheap labor base
but in the end who is getting squeezed
and who's going to be the most affected
your middle to lower income levels
blacks and hispanics
are going to be the ones that suffer
with the scourge of illegal immigration
i like what you said about free does not
mean freedom because we
built a system of law and rule that has
enabled us to be free
to experience freedom in our system like
you have to abide by a strict rule of
law
so that you don't get jumped when you're
walking down the street and you can feel
free outside
uh just dispensing with the rules in
this antarctic free society does not
lead to freedom as we understand it
no it doesn't and and when you think
about what was going on i mean you grew
up in chicago
and i remember seeing the riots that
were happening in chicago with these
black lives matter social justice
warriors and they were going in and
busting up
all of those stores on the uh the the
million miles
magnificent magnificent mile and what
were they saying this is how we're going
to get our reparations
that's that a woman is actually quoted
as saying that she didn't care when when
asked about the right she said
this is reparations as far as she's
concerned there's a video of a guy
firing a
gun into the window of one of these
shops trying to steal
luxury merchandise look i'm not a big
fan
of like luxury brands i think it's you
know can be a bit pompous
but i'm i i think it's fine people have
that stuff i don't think someone should
go and shoot guns and steal it because
they think they're owed something
no but it was defended in the media and
that's the sad thing and that's the
breakdown
of the rule of law and order remember
that you know when john locke
wrote his second treatise of government
and he talked about
this thing you know that was completely
different it was natural rights theory
that was different from divine rights
theory and john locke came out and said
that there are three inalienable rights
that we have from our creator it's life
liberty
and property and what do you see
happening with the left
all you got to do is go to the communist
manifesto by karl marx
it is about taking away that individual
right to property
and that is what you see happening in
america now it's a wealth redistribution
scheme that says
i don't care how much you work hard tim
i don't care how successful your podcast
is
i don't care how well you're doing here
ian it is our right as the government to
come in and take it away from you and
redistribute it to someone else
that ain't freedom i had a good
conversation with uh with a socialist
i think it was the socialist party of
great britain or something and uh
they basically said when when i brought
up that point about property
they said no no you don't understand in
socialism you're allowed personal
property
it's very different from like a watch
right so so when they said they're
banning private property i'm like so
well i can't have clothes
and they're like no no no that's
personal property private property is
like a building
and i'm like okay so let's let's try and
find that line of where you split
personal property from private property
they were trying to explain that private
property in their system means the means
of production
the the factory nationalizing production
well so here's the question i had
okay well i do my work by filming myself
with a camera
the camera is my means of production my
factory essentially
should that camera be owned by someone
else or should it be my personal
property
didn't really have a good answer for it
because you there it's it's a it's a
weasel word excuse
for some justification for seizing
people's private property absolutely
personal property is meaningless your
shoes okay but what about my car
what about my bike what about my food my
refrigerator my home
where do you draw the line and they said
ultimately well we don't necessarily
know of course you don't know your
system is magic it doesn't make sense
and it's broke
it has never been successful and so
let's take that
philosophy and let's over plant it to
the last
year dealing with this covett issue
show me in the constitution where any
elected official has the enumerated
power
to decide who or what is essential in
the united states of america
show me you've done it but yeah but show
me in the constitution coming back to
your state about the rule of law and
freedom
show me in the constitution where it
says that any elected official
politician can come to you and say shut
down
your business shut down your livelihood
but yet i will continue to be paid
isn't the 14th amendment barring them
from doing that
that people must be treated equal
protection under the law yeah absolutely
but but see when you have the ability to
redefine the law or fundamentally
transform the law
and say that well you know we don't
really know what it is but we're kind of
deciding as we go along and if we
continue to have
and let me say this correctly when we
move from being
people to being sheeple we are allowing
ourselves to be
fear-mongered and intimidated into
surrendering our
everyday liberties and rights remember
what benjamin franklin said
those who would surrender essential
liberty for temporary security will
in the end deserve neither liberty nor
security and lose both
and lose both they won't deserve either
so that's what we're talking about when
we say free does not equal freedom
if you want something to give you
something for free you're surrendering
your freedom to that person
let me ask you you you bring up the
constitution and uh election elected
officials
right to tell you to close your business
my response is i think the 14th
amendment says equal protection
under the law do you think that's fair
to say that these politicians
uh these states are by chance violating
the constitution of the united states
absolutely they are and and as a matter
of fact you have had
several state supreme courts that have
come back and said
hey what our governors did with these
mandates edicts orders and decrees were
unconstitutional we are a constitutional
republic
that means we are governed by a rule of
law we are not a constitutional monarchy
where someone sits up like ram sees
pharaoh and says so let it be everything
so let it be done and we're supposed to
all fall down like subjects we're
citizens
and and i think that's what's so
important if there's one message
i can get to the young people you've got
to understand
the structure of this government you've
got to understand
the roles and responsibilities of the
respective branches you got to
understand your rights
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8 p.m where you can leave
comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you